well Nevada has a green goal to be 50
clean energy by the year 2030. carbon
car emissions one of the biggest hurdles
of course in our state's most populous
County proposing a big move to help
reach that goal but it could cost
developers Ryan Matthew joins us live in
studio with this potential and what it
could mean for most new builds in the
New Year Ryan yeah Christian Kirsten the
valley it's always developing homes
shops hotels you can't miss it but while
it keeps growing Clark County wants
electric vehicle charging infrastructure
to be part of it it's the green thing to
do government officials say but
mandating it is what developers call the
costly thing to do
foreign
it will cost more but definitely not
breaking the bank what Clark County's
Department of environment and
sustainability director Marcy Henson
believes can move faster if finding one
of these was easier we want to make sure
that we have the infrastructure ready
for when that market transformation
takes place and that people feel
confident that they can get from place
to place and they're not going to run
low on their battery it's through an
ordinance Clark County Commissioners
will consider Tuesday a mandate
requiring EV charging stations and
capabilities in all new multi-family
residents shopping centers Resorts
schools industrial parks government
centers and most other new builds there
could be potential over regulation a
concern for some developers like Rod
Martin co-chair of the neop Southern
Nevada government Affairs committee I
think in a lot of those commercial
applications it is applicable and again
where you just start getting question is
should it be everywhere a move he says
many developers are already doing and
others say should be left to them CCSD D
adding in public comment it's concern of
bearing the cost amidst an already six
billion dollar shortfall in bond dollars
the Southern Nevada homebuilders
Association telling 8 news now its
willingness to accept change but caution
of balancing future planning with
potential negative impacts to the
housing market and amidst fears the
state's electrical grid could be
overwhelmed by it there's a lot of
complications to it that still need to
be sorted out
now yes those installation costs may be
up front but it comes as the inflation
reduction act rolls out that provides
certain tax incentives and rebates for
developers who are putting in this
infrastructure meaning pay now see those
results and pay a little bit later back
to you guys thank you Ryan if approved
tomorrow it could go into effect between
the spring and summer time also in the
New Year assembly Bill 44 goes into
effect it provides more funding for
these charging capabilities in
low-income homes and neighborhoods